I'm going through a lot of my stuff and
I'm struggling with determining what is
something I should donate and what is
something that I should try and make a
profit from so I see value in these
items not necessarily value for myself
and and my lifestyle but I do see value
or potential for you know making a few a
few bucks here in there like on shoes or
clothes but I also think that it's
easier for me to just drop off a box at
the goodwill and donate but I'm
struggling with making that
determination as far as what would make
me happy would it make me happy to
donate these items to someone who might
find use for them or would it make me
happy to you know make me try and make a
profit off of these items that I don't
find value in so Ryan I can't tell
Cristina what's going to make her happy
necessarily but there are a few like
sort of key words that I might rephrase
if I were her the first thing she asked
a question or really made the statement
she's struggling to determine whether
she should donate or try to make a
profit from these things I wouldn't try
to make a profit from the things that
you're selling because you probably
bought them when they were new yeah and
you're probably unless it's some sort of
weird Hummel collector's item
in most cases you're going to lose the
vast majority of the value you paid for
the thing because most of the
possessions that we own are depreciating
right assets and in fact in her case
they're not even assets at all they're
liabilities now alright because she's
she isn't getting value from them in
fact she's getting what I would call
negative value which would be a really
good title for an essay podcast Sean we
should we should craft something like
that but um the the the negative value
of the stuff because there is this
additional weight there's the
psychological weight of holding on to
these things the refusal to let go and
that causes I mean clearly she's calling
out so it causes what anxiety discontent
stress overwhelm
and and maybe it's not a high level of
stress but it's this low level of
anxiety that is ebbing throughout her
life and that adds up over time man yeah
I mean it's a clear sign that she's got
to do something with those things you
know it's funny
Christina if you were to just as a
Christina Chris yeah Christina I got a
right prayer goes by Christine for short
anyway Christine no no I I'm just I'm
messing myself up um
Christina what I was gonna say is you
could donate everything right now
you know I turn this podcast off right
now and donate everything and you're
gonna be okay like there's no doubt
about that
so the question isn't whether or not you
know what's the right decision meaning
oh you know if I don't sell this stuff
then I'm gonna miss out on some money
like you didn't really expect to have
that money to begin with
right so it'd be like if you if I was
walking down the sidewalk and I saw one
hundred dollar bill on the sidewalk I
mean of course I'm gonna pick it up but
if I didn't pick it up my life wouldn't
be any different Christina your life
isn't gonna be any different if you
donate every single one of these things
now so any money what you're saying any
money that she does make if she does
decide to sell any of it sort of a
windfall in a way yeah pretty much
so look at it that way as anything that
you sell is you know kind of gravy on
top and then you got to decide how much
of gravy you want Christina maybe maybe
it's good to set up some rules around
this because I think what she's facing
right now is she sort of paralyzed by
that that decision right where remember
the the Seth Godin that sa you and I
were talking about the other day where
he's talking about the cancelling
something like it's something that
you're putting off cancel cancel the
thing so so in in this sort of analogy
here you want to cancel these items
right you want to cancel these physical
items and then give yourself one week to
do something with them yes so just to
rephrase what you're saying is she needs
to set an end date for all of these
things to be out of her house yeah and
one or two things are going to happen
well a she has to commit to that ending
non-negotiable pick a date stick to it
that's step number one
right and then the second step is yeah
you're either gonna be Christina's gonna
be motivated to sell that stuff or the
end dates gonna come and she's gonna be
like yeah they really have time to sell
I'm just gonna go ahead and donate
but either way she's got an honor that
end date no I totally agree man so um so
maybe the let's put some parameters
around out my own life when I was a
question I would ask her a few questions
one is do you have any debt then I would
be more aggressive about selling things
to try to pay off the debt yeah I
certainly don't want to come across like
you know if there's something sitting
there for 20 that she can sell for $20
20 bucks is 20 bucks and if it's easy
for her to sell that item and get 20
bucks then do that leg we're not we're
not saying to just yet don't worry about
the money you're right if she has debt
that's more of a reason for her to dig
into it but this is what she's got to
ask herself how long is it gonna take me
to sell that item for $20 yeah because
your time yeah if it's gonna take her 20
hours to sell an item for $20 she's got
a post-it she's got a you know filter
through all the people trying to you
know pay half as much she has to repost
it if it expires and she doesn't get to
print so yes she has to figure out what
her time is worth absolutely yeah and
that's an individual question right
everybody's billionaires whose time I
mean they'd be better off just donating
the car because the amount of time it
takes selling a car would just not be
worth it for them because their their
time is worth a particular dollar amount
yeah now neither one of us are
millionaires or especially not
billionaires and and so you have to take
that into consideration what is your
time worth put a dollar amount on it but
then also what is the psychological cost
that goes on top of that because let's
say your time you know you're working
somewhere and you're making twenty bucks
an hour then you can say well my time
was worth twenty dollars an hour and if
I can sell this one item in half an hour
for twenty dollars well then I'm making
forty bucks an hour that makes a whole
lot of sense for me to sell this thing
however just because you think you can
sell something for twenty bucks doesn't
mean you necessarily will and so that's
why I think that end date of a week is
so important I used to say thirty days
when I read that Seth Godin essay it was
like oh we'll put a link to that in the
show notes Shawn it's about it's about
cancelling big projects and saying I'm
either gonna cancel this or I'm gonna
take massive action on the thing and I
think that's really where Christina is
right now and and I would be even more
aggressive with selling things if I had
debt and so for me I'd put some
parameters around that we have something
called the 3030 rule when it comes to
buying new things and it's if something
costs more than $30 then I'm gonna wait
at least 30 hours to bring it into my
life well maybe you you take a iteration
of that rule and you make that
applicable to your life where hey maybe
if I can get more than 30 bucks for this
or whatever your time was worth and I
spend less than an hour on on that
whatever that dollar amount is for the
hour and I'm gonna spend less in an hour
trying to sell this thing now for me i
bei became my best friend when I was
trying to get out of debt and selling a
bunch of things yeah there were for me
it was above 20 bucks anything over 20
bucks I would try to put it on eBay and
I didn't always succeed I held on to
some of those things way too long
because of the sunk cost fallacy right
yeah that you nailed it dude she's got
to get comfortable son cost I mean that
is that is ultimately where this is
leading so she's gonna decide okay here
are the things that I can get some money
out of here are the things that are
worth my time to sell and everything
else it is sunk cost you're never gonna
get that that that money back that you
paid for those items but it's okay
because maybe someone else will get
value out of those items and then you've
created a you know situation for someone
else to have something maybe they
typically would not have had if it
wasn't for you donating that to a you
know your favorite donation or your
favorite charity or whatever it may be
let's talk about a few of those
charities so if you're selling stuff I
reckon I mean I tend recommend 3 places
to people because this is what I've I've
used two of them I've not used the third
one yeah if you're selling stuff
Craigslist has really my go to it oh
yeah
in fact we go back she just sold her car
on on Craigslist you know two weeks ago
and someone came out from Idaho to pick
up the car and it all worked out so
Craigslist is a great place to sell
things you're also gonna get inundated
with spammers and and you have to
consider that as part of the cost there
are gonna be people who email you excuse
me madam is the item still for sale I'm
stuck in the UK but I have but I have a
business friend in America who would
like to take a look at your car in order
to pay you nine thousand dollars you
need to wire me $500 first to make sure
that and so you're gonna you have to be
very weary of that but Craigslist is a
great place to sell especially bigger on
recently we sold an old coffee table on
Craigslist we sold an old Inn table and
it wasn't all it was just it was old to
us we weren't using it anymore from when
Beck's and I combined households and
then we had this extra table on this
other extra table in table and sold the
because it was like perfect timing to
his kids going back to school and
they're like yeah we'll buy that for 50
bucks or 100 bucks even though the sunk
costed me was like no that table cost me
two hundred and fifty dollars and my
first reaction to that is I should sell
for 240 then and if we get back to
Christina's original question what she's
saying is well I'm trying to figure out
whether whether or not I should make a
profit well for me that would mean I
have to sell the table for 260 bucks and
then I'm just going to hold on to that
begrudgingly for a long time and that
psychological cost is going to compound
there's compound interest on some of the
psychological cost a little bit of
anxiety you're feeling right now will be
twice as much a month from now a year
from now all of a sudden you're stressed
out you don't realize why and it's that
fear of letting go and so I think I
think Christina if you want to sell the
stuff you have to give yourself a
timeline so pick 10 things that you
really feel good about selling that's
worth your time selling sell those
things if you can't sell them the first
week then donate them oh the third place
I would recommend selling stuff is
Poshmark and only reason I know about
that place is because podcast Sean's
wife sells some stuff off Josh mark from
time there was another charity you
wanted to bring up oh so that those are
the places to sell there's a few places
with respect to charities because a lot
of charities are so localized a goodwill
is that the big exception I really like
Goodwill I enjoy donating stuff to
Goodwill for a couple reasons one is
it's convenient
two is they have 2,700 donation
locations yeah around around the United
States and they the in but I understand
people's aversion to it because like
well if I donate my clothes they're
gonna sell it and then how I make sure
those clothes get to people in need well
goodwill of still a charity they take
that money last year I think they made
two point eight billion dollars and 84
percent of which is used for charitable
giving that non overhead related
expenses that's pretty phenomenal it's
pretty awesome a charity that uses a
they're a United Way I doubt it uses 84%
of their revenue the their donations to
for charitable goods and so they in fact
let's put a link there they're in in the
show notes to show a lot of the good
that goodwill does without getting
bogged down in the stats of it goodwill
does a ton of good now now one thing
Ryan the day that that is difficult that
to get over so that will they pay their
CEO a lot of money
well apparently their CEO manages the
the company really well and they are
able to donate eighty four percent of
the revenue they make as a result isn't
that a good thing yeah it's never
bothered me that they make money off of
a dude ever it's never I've never even
thought about it until someone said
something like oh I don't do that
because I'm giving them something for
free and then they're selling it but
it's like they have the infrastructure
they have the means and it's not like
they're trying to gouge people with
their prices I mean I don't if you've
ever shopped at Goodwill I know both of
us have and like dude they're not
gouging for prices so I am totally happy
to give my goods to someone who has the
infrastructure to redistribute those
goods to people who actually need them
like I have that has never bothered me
now well I think that if you're a woman
and you have clothes to donate maybe the
best place is not to donate to Goodwill
because especially if you have like
professional clothes there's a charity
called Dress for Success and what they
do is they help women who are
interviewing or they're they're trying
to they're trying to get professional
clothes and so though I believe don't
even pick it up for you so Dress for
Success we'll put a link to that in the
show notes and the last thing I want to
recommend because
charities are so the donation places are
so hyper localized like I remember back
in Missoula we would go to a donation
warehouse and in fact they would pick
stuff up from you in fact we bought some
furniture from them when we first met
Missoula yeah that's how we learned
about them and people were donating
their stuff and so we got value from
some of the things we bought from them
relatively inexpensively and then
they'll pick up your old mattresses and
stuff like that but you probably don't
have donation warehouse wherever you
live if you're listening to this unless
you're in Missoula but if you go to
donation town
org that's how I found donation
warehouse you just type in your zip code
and it'll tell you well here are the
three places in or near your zip code
that will come pick up and it's very
specific I'll pick up mattresses this
place will pick up toys this place will
pick up anything and so if you go to
donation town or you can find the local
charity for you or if that doesn't help
you out especially with things like
batteries those are hard to get rid of
you know especially we live in
California it's illegal for us to throw
out batteries in the trash can hmm Oh
Best Buy takes them here but and so does
Target but wherever you are you can just
google where do I don't or where do I
recycle batteries where where do i
donate blank in your local area and
you'll find like the the specific
charity to which you can donate these
these excess things that you're not able
to sell yeah Christina I mean really get
clear on what you want your your life to
look like or what you want your your the
things in your house how do you want
them to to appear in your house what
spaces do you want to fill up whatever
it is like just get clear on what that
ideal scenario is anything that
distracts you from getting to that
scenario you've got a oh we need another
towel okay Shawn you have a small towel
what I'm getting at is is like we will
start to flinch at stuff yeah we'll
start to flinch at oh you know I this is
how I want my life to be but in order to
get it that way I need to get rid of
this one thing I know that one thing I
paid a hundred bucks for and maybe I
could get twenty bucks out of it those
those little barriers those little
hurdles jump over them as quick as
possible yeah if that means just
donating your stuff like I promise you
Christina's could be way more worth it
to you than just to just get rid of it
than it is to sit here and worry about
every little nickel and dime that you
can make officer because the the price
tag or the money involved is only one
component of a much bigger recipe and I
love what you just said about having a
vision because that vision is going to
keep you on track it's sort of the
horizon or the destination the direction
is probably a better way to put it your
vision is the direction in which you
want to travel now you'll get where your
house is closer to your
and the vision might shift a little bit
it might pivot slightly or my pivot
significantly once you start letting go
of some of these things and you're like
wow I can let go of more this is this is
freeing I feel lighter my house is way
easier to clean once you start getting
rid of these things and you get that
that momentum and that momentum carries
you forward letting go builds the muscle
of letting go even more
you